I was also not to bring it down a little
bit but I also was fascinated with the
your
um
your amazing words in the tragedy of the
loss of your parents who uh you know
died in a fire right well uh uh carbon
uh carbon monoxide yeah yeah they lit up
they didn't have the flu yeah right and
they both and you were in the midst of a
tour yeah and made the decision in that
moment and then that to not
leave the tour you just continued like
even that night doing a show I don't
know how but yeah that seemed like
Monumental uh strength and you know it's
it's something I would not have wanted
to do uh I would have rather just like
crawled into a hole and not not seen
anybody for for a month uh but I was the
fact was I was on the middle in the
middle of a tour and you know a lot of
people were depending on me I've got a
whole band and whole crew that you know
they they made sacrifices to be part of
the tour I've got a lot of people that
bought tickets that were you know in
their seats and you know I didn't want
to disrupt everybody else's life so I I
tried to you know just suck it up and
and try to you know as a lot of um kind
of denial like pretending like
everything was okay to go out on stage
and you know smile and do a comedy show
and you know even though like inside I
was just crumbling
um so yeah it was not it was not a an
easy thing to get through but I I but
also amazing
um
it kind of speaks to who you are and it
was kind of you know I I remember
reading about it when it happened and I
remember and like I I kept thinking and
I'm I don't think I'm alone is I would
not be able to
I wish I could do that you are an
amazing human being for just your
ability to do that you know and when
when you speak it of such loss and
personal tragedy the ability to even for
a moment think about other people to
think about you know your band the
people you work with the people that are
depending on you and then again last but
not least maybe this can distract me for
a moment and get me out of the darkness
but you thought of other people at that
time kind of speaks volumes to the man
they raised it's a great legacy for you
parents that you were able to do that
yeah thanks it was uh it was one of
those kind of things I I'm kind of a The
Show Must Go On kind of guy and also I
don't like to put people out and and I
didn't even want people to really know
about it I figured I want to keep this
you know misery to myself and not have
people not walk out on stage and have
people feeling sorry for me because it's
a comedy show I don't want did they know
did that audience that night it was big
news I remember I knew that was the
thing it was like I was thinking it was
going to be a very quiet thing and I was
not even gonna tell the the crew I was
just gonna like I didn't want people
walking on eggshells around me but like
within an hour it was like worldwide
news right so people knew about it so I
I had to address that I had to you know
uh I think we put something up on a
screen saying that tonight's performance
is dedicated to the memory of my parents
uh so we we addressed it and then we
just kind of had to move on and
do a comedy show and I think you know it
was it was nice for me because I got a
lot of love and support from the fans I
mean people knew what I was putting
myself through even just to be there to
be on stage uh and and I I really felt
an extra dose of love coming from people
and and uh again it's not something that
I would have chosen to do to perform in
that context but but it was cathartic
for me it really you know you know it
meant a lot to me to know the people
were you know supporting me and grieving
with me and and and and helping me get
through it but they got the good news is
they got to see your success
and meet my my child yeah
[Music]